Hey look a good Captain Marvel movie I'm
very amused with DC's interpretation of
the Monster Squad especially at the end
this this was like a lost 80s movie that
was spliced together like a cheesy 90s
superhero movie probably starring Shaq
eighties kids pills yeah this is this is
like the Lost eighties kids film that
like never got released is it I I was
blown away I was I was very amused by
how wildly inappropriate this movie was
for children kids would like and laugh
it up again it is like Monster Squad is
like oh it is hard to say this is what
all the kids in the audience like
watching this is like demon monsters
tear apart this boardroom meeting and
they walk into strip clubs I was like it
just warms my heart their kids are like
or something like drinking beer him like
buying the beer in like it I I don't
know like I miss these type of movies we
grew up on where it's just like they
like kind of wanted to get kids into see
it or they had crossover appeal but it's
like not really really a kids movie now
let's see what happens when Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker that's a crossover what
Sam that's the movie this is really one
of those disease did like Disney Marvel
I think really actually has real
competition like legit competition yeah
yeah we've gotten like so far this year
we've gotten extremely like we had Sony
head into the spider-verse you know on
the manga
we had yeah yeah in the manga firm we
have battle angel Aleta which was
amazing and then on the DC front you
know you saw man I didn't know you said
it was really good and this was really
amazing
Wonder Woman as well it's a while ago
now but yeah Disney Marvel like the
Joker looks amazing then they've got
competition though I finally I feel like
DC can be viable competent like and I
know we always get accused SD Marvel's
hate I would love for DC to put a DC
Warner Warner DC I should say put out
great movies like more like this please
like yeah not now they're kind of on
that vibe and what I like to uh about
like this in Aquaman definitely Wonder
Woman to is that you don't have to shy
away from the dark stuff they're still
yeah allowing it to be there but they're
being smart about they're being clever
about it like this is a silly film but
at the same time they will have not only
scary imagery and stuff that's kind of
inappropriate for kids but also like
some weight to some of the scenes about
like there's a boss rate being a
handicapped kid as well I mean like that
but there's a speed just like was just
jealous yeah no shit
yeah like I'm completely talking about
boy stuff yeah wouldn't it be awesome
and you're just wasting your parent like
that scene with something like this is
really like catch you off guard like
it's one of those scenes and Christ all
the kids in this aren't just great
actors from one form on up until I've
not seen Dumbo yet but from what I'm
this is like the anti Dumbo because
apparently like the the kid actors never
really wooden and flat and I love even
even the valu the littlest girl like at
first I thought I was like ah this is
this is gonna happen this is yeah this
could be like you know one of the Cosby
kids they're like oh the Olsen twins
kind of like too cute and I'm like now
honestly after like first couple scenes
I thought she was actually really good
well and whatnot they set up very early
on that like this is kind of how she
like this isn't normal kids meek and
everybody kind of knows
yes we're in their own right and that's
kind of her kind of weird and you know
something that I realized watching this
movie I wonder if you agree of me or not
I didn't think this film was
phenomenally written like it's not badly
written but there's there's a lot of
jokes where I'm like if a nominally
direct yeah if I read a lot of this I
would be like well that's not bad by oh
no you got to punch up a line or two you
got maybe a little funny or maybe
connect this a little more or something
like that but the direction and the
acting and the style and the mood I mean
the way it goes back and forth from just
incredibly silly to legitimately really
dark yeah - hilarious ly dark -
hilariously light it surprisingly really
balances out hilariously dark
hilariously light and then somewhere in
the middle like an independent film vibe
of like you know some boy just searching
for his mom and trying out now being a
foster kid like it I know it just really
worked it worked in a way like I
remember when I saw Terminator 2 when I
was like oh like 12 maybe I'm a
big-screen and I remember it was like
the first time where I felt like in a
while I'm like there's a real kid yeah
like those are real kids like that's how
we talked that's how we act and like
this is a little this is more pg-13
versus an r-rated film though and this
time Mike's cage I feel like it gets
close in this movie yeah they definitely
drop they don't show the gloves but like
it's it gets Jurassic Park violent with
like the demons this guy's basically
first time in a while I've seen Santa
drops the f-bomb quite a few times near
the end that was one of the best running
jokes I have one poor Santa how many
like the dark moments worried this is
like Santa will always be there for you
and like some villain attacks and he
like just tosses the girls like this
movie just goes dark places and it's
hilarious boy yeah but but again it's
smart about it and yes funny about it's
got it's got real heart so that you can
laugh at the dark moment yeah you like
it always
makes it back to these really likable
characters and they just ease even if
they're not funny at times they are just
so charming and I am just so unboard
with these kids and I'm never annoyed
with them and there's a lot of kids in
this movie uh again if you were to tell
me throughout this film would go like
you just tell me I'd be like oh yeah
that's suck but I mean they just play
with it so well and just make them so
likable and it's so clever what they do
with it yeah we won't get into spoilers
but they knew how to tell a simple story
really effectively well because the
descript the lines themselves are not
brilliant but the actual story itself
it's it's it's very straightforward it's
very simple yeah it's very simple and it
works because the directions great and
the acting is great and they like they
kind of just pull the material up and
just run wild with it and then what I
like to is when a moment would come up
you know that they they set up a lot but
it doesn't feel like too much in the
opening where when something else would
come back into the story I was kind of
like oh yeah but it wasn't a sense of
there's too much going on I can't keep
it all together it's that I was having
so much fun with the rest of it that
when another element was reintroduced I
was like oh yeah that's what's going out
with that yeah that's right is he gonna
find that or is this guy gonna you know
get the power to this or whatever and it
legitimately excites me when that
happened I liked it a lot too because it
shows that you can take anything so
stupid because let's be honest this is I
mean that those and even those original
comics
we're so that the ones in the forties
like they're like Captain Marvel this
Shazam like so goofy I'm assuming they
didn't change the costumes at all no
that was the cops yeah which makes it
I'm not I'm not I'm not like Shazam
aficionado I'm just like I'm like just
aware of it because it's kind of a
classic but it I want to say it had a
run-in with like Superman people thought
it was too similar which is why I like
kind of a Superman comparison yeah all
the comparisons it's like a big in joke
but it it shows that you can take
something so goofy so stupid and still
give it depth character and meaning yeah
so that when people try to say like oh
well it's a comic book movie you don't
need things like that you can just have
fun and like you know I'm I'm looking at
spider-man homecoming I'm looking at
some of the other ones that people just
like no you still need to care about
these characters I love your obnoxious
and voice cuz it's just kind of like
someone pushes you in oh you can take
any idea that's stupid as all hell and
you can still like I was totally
invested in this kid I was invested in
his foster family I was invest in the
story with his mother and everything and
he literally has a giant lightning bolt
and you know there's a Sam
yes Sam it's a stupid as hell but like
it shows you that you can take any dumb
idea into the spider-verse did this tune
like that's still that's still probably
my favorite I'm and then I think was an
a-plus movie in this to me as an a movie
but like it that was another one where
it's like it's a conceptual dare and you
still invested it with all this meaning
and it's the best damn spider-man movie
ever made
yeah so enough with the excuses like I
think it's time like know we can make
comic book movies that can be goofy and
fun and silly a DC comic book movie even
and still give it a whole bunch of
meaning give it darkness like this movie
got really dark at certain points it was
great it's so that weight to it
surprisingly that I really did not
expect I was expecting to be no
run-of-the-mill like Disney Channel
moral like okay I'm sure I'll have
something cuz it's a kid trying to adult
all that stuff but I mean it's like I
didn't know there was gonna be scenes
where I'm like legitimately sad to watch
just like a dangly drama on the Sun yeah
sometimes uh and I do we will never let
him do another comic with me I legit
just before I forget I really like the
nod to big in this movie
all I was thinking of it's like this I
like it big wasn't superhero and then
when they have the nod I was just like
okay it's just a little one but Bravo
good it's again it's like all the stuff
on the piano that end up with the piano
the taps on the piano that lead to a
literal punch line yeah well that's
there are so many just brilliant
decisions and cuts and like this is like
this is basically how you save an okay
script and make it better you get
talented filmmakers out of the actors
talented actors I think this is this is
where I think the other Captain Marvel
like blue and I think the direction was
not good I can't really say if it's the
actor's fault because who knows the DNA
were given but yeah I mean this is this
is a night and day difference well we'll
know more by endgame if real arson is
really good and that that would be like
okay it was my whole shit I hope the
Russo brothers are able to like pull
someone okay she was in room she was
very good that's the thing I've seen her
good in things well it's the it's the
Kristen Wiig um the Ghostbusters thing
where it's like she was so flat in that
but like I've seen you be really really
funny did the director just tell you no
play it like this yeah but but everyone
in here just especially all actors
there's like and there's very I mean
like really really young and and some
older and stuff and just yeah the way
they they play it and then the adult
actors who have to you know that play
them later and they just do such a great
job he did like great impressions in lay
you could tell they probably had to have
hung out on the set for a day or two
like what sound like it was really them
like well what's the name is AG yeah the
guy John Sam the guy Alvin the Chipmunks
- yeah oh my god the guy who to me looks
like he's just one hair removed from
Jimmy Fallon yeah he uh for the most
part I had no problem believing he was
this kid this face yeah I mean it's
really remind me a lot of Tom Hanks
playing the kid in big cuz it's like may
you just totally buy it the only time
where I kind of when I don't know and
maybe it's just his voice I'm not sure
is whenever he was like afraid or
yelling
it's what got a little higher like this
and I'm like you're doing a kid
impression right there I feel like the
kid wins necessarily I must fine with it
just cuz maybe that's his natural
screaming voice I'm not sure I'm fine
with there because it is still kind of a
comedy and I thought it kind of just
made it funny yeah but the God every
like every child actor and this was just
amazing I'm like I want I want sequels
to this really bad like this yeah this
is like the third one now don't give it
away don't give it away but I mean like
you'll just see the big credit sequence
and be like what the hell's gonna happen
you ask me it's like I knew well I just
wanna make sure wasn't something I was
missing who / what that was
yeah you know and I just wanna make sure
it wasn't something like I was missing
it's like oh no no but now it makes me
one is in the comics yeah it's kind of
hard to find stuff but it's just this
like this year alone I'm like I want
sequels tuned to the spider-verse I want
sequels to Aleta and I wanna sequels to
this now yeah um we're getting a sequel
to Wonder Woman I'm finally happy cuz I
was like hoping that Wonder Woman would
kickstart something you know where we'd
start getting good DC films and yet
those slip-ups afterwards but like
Wonder Woman's another one that I won
you can give me a hundred sequels to
that I'll be fine like those were all
great movies well and even I guess you
could argue a castaway after Wonder
Woman was it just Justice League and
they all said Suicide Squad was after
was before I could be wrong but part of
the but okay so Wonder Woman was like
good it was a really good movie and
there's like a surprise hit it's like
they were kind of locked into those two
already it's like landing buddy they're
already on the approximate out like
Justice League I mean when I do their
view I still stand by this is okay if
there's a ton of stuff you can point out
is wrong about it and is it good but I'm
like just for a turn your brain on which
is not what your
no but that's what I'm saying I can't
wonder in fact her Wonder Woman like did
that it's kind of spite did they start
getting kind of good from there I'd be
obvious a lot better than I feel no I
feel like those were already pre doomed
because it was like they were already
well planned out what Wonder Woman was
like you know in production and stuff
like these things now are getting crazy
with the attempts of an extended
universe but that's the well now they
don't even have their Batman or Superman
yeah it's like screw the DC EU these
films are better anyway they should just
start doing this I say if Marvel goes
extended universe DC right now maybe
they should do the opposite just you
know what why don't we just put out
really good movies I get in this movie I
thought it was entertaining and cool
that like it is weird that it's set in
Philly I would have probably like come
up with a fake city but it I do like
that there's a metropolis a Gotham if
there's a Superman there's Batman so the
idea is there around yeah you know I
like that they shot in Philly and I like
that it's a Christmas movie
well no very bizarre that Christmas yeah
but no it's not that
Philly's a gorgeous city it's not that
they can shoot it in Philly I didn't
know I was kind of wondering I'm like
does it take me out of it a bit like I'm
trying to think of like another DC
property and it would be like oh yeah
there's a Gotham City metropolis but
we're set we're in Chicago and I'm just
like maybe you should just come up with
a fictional city name and all the
references do can you do this like
Superman q do this like Batman this felt
like a world cuz they know what
superheroes are and they want to mimic
them like kids so I felt that it really
worked that there are a super alpha
superheroes in this but there's not even
though they mentioned them there's not
really like whatever the flash makes a
cameo here Batman makes a cameo here
like there's one technically and it's
really just a throwaway J yeah like yeah
this is the really their own movies it
doesn't have to be one giant like
interconnected like ya know Wonder Woman
did yeah
it's like they've got no more a second
II like ya need to do it like them and
I'm like why if I want that I'll just go
to Marvel maybe I like you DC because
you do things different well let's be on
so they try to copy like with the Joker
a trailer it's first of all technically
it's already that can be in the same
universe because we have a Jared Leto
Joker so I don't know what we're gonna
do with this DC Universe thing but it's
like you know that Joker you know it has
to be something very different that like
that looks like its own movie it doesn't
look like well now he's gonna go and get
in the fight with Batman or something
and the no baby no cameo by yeah it
looks like it's just its own beautiful
movie like ready to go
it could suck it looks really good I
think should I think this movie yeah
this movie laid out a great template for
rather do this was like acknowledge
they're out there maybe you can have a
cameo a movie but that's it you don't
need to like you know really
interconnect them then yeah yeah here we
go it's Kevin you know kind of thing and
yeah like you said to this was a very
simple story but it had just enough
elements going on and just enough
enjoyability where you're just going man
whenever something else comes up or
comes back you're legitimately excited
and you don't feel exhausted by it it's
like just the right amount oh yeah and
it's a long movie and I know doesn't
feel like you never once felt yeah I
never once I was waiting for it I'm like
at some point cuz like the only thing I
didn't like about Wonder Woman the only
thing is like that third act like kind
of fell apart a bit and I'm just like ah
just kept going and going this that's
the one thing like I still love Wonder
Woman a lot but that's the one thing
this has over there which is like man
did they pace it perfectly and it
doesn't yell apart at the end kind of
like Wonder Woman kind of like got a
little heavy at the end where it's like
just too much going on but this one was
just so perfectly paced beginning to end
and then the climax was fun and scary
and like but my favorite is that that
scene where they're there in that like
they do like these spoofy kind of
moments they're like the villain and
Shazam are flying the villains played by
Moby I'm convinced by the way it's
that's all I could think of looking at
they're like flying next to each other
and
buildings are like in between them and
the villains like looking at Shazam like
earned Shazam's look at the middle iron
like go like this and at one point the
villain keeps going and Shazam does not
come out the other side of the building
and you realize that he just totally
faked him out and I'm like why don't
more superheroes do that that's why I
think this dream yes there's a couple
times where he like he's given a
monologue and he's like I can't hear you
you're like a mile away like two trucks
and planes like are you giving some bad
guys species mocked for it in the movie
you know rightfully so he's a hero but I
do kind of like it does shows sometimes
the value of running away back into a
kid and fellies and it's kind of like I
like it he's like he thinks like a kid
and but like a resourceful kid I'm like
I I buy that a kid would like do this
thing and be like okay I gotta say
Shazam and duck out of here cuz I would
get my ass kicked
there's one there's one thing that comes
to mind again it's it's a nitpick but in
terms of like the emotional journey and
everything else kind of like huh and
that they make a big deal out of him
flying and like and you see him kind of
fly at one point says Kiwi buildings a
single ballot and he tries it and he
just goes into a billion he doesn't
sorry but then later in the movie like
he's trying to fly again and he can do
it and it's like wow you can fly and
it's like yeah we covered that I guess
he can fly better now I mean that's like
the one thing where I was like that's a
little weird but like there's a lot
going on in that script I again that's
why I'm kind of amazed it's as good as
it is because the the script kind of
felt slightly unpolished like I give you
one more rewrite yeah maybe not even a
total reboot of it just like it strip a
few things here let's make sure a bunch
of nines yeah yeah but I mean the
direction and acting were so good that
you kind of did and the production
doesn't like everything else was so good
you kind of didn't notice it which is so
rare yeah normally if there's a bad
script it just wrecks things this is one
of rare times where it's just like the
script
bad by any stretch but it wasn't like oh
this is the world's greatest script it
was one of those where I'm like god
that's an alright script I wouldn't
think it would lead to a movie this good
no and when it would leave it would lead
to like a b-movie B plus B - ever but
but not like an a movie yes an A I agree
I think this is one of the stronger ones
yeah it's just it's a solid movie if you
look at the trailer you like yeah that
looks funny that looks like fun i-it's
like plus it is clam gremlins - yes I
love that he was loved did Batman and
Robin oh yeah that's afraid you're going
to have to talk Ted woman you look great
terrible eyes talk about the 2,000 pound
Austrian gorilla in the room the coin is
a space nice to see you too big boy so
this this is a little better than Batman
a rabbit just a little but that's what's
weird though is like there are moments
where it feels like it came from that
same era like it's so cheesy like it was
it steal Jack won yeah then what was the
other one there was another one right
there's a bunch of or my just a gonna
kiss I feel like that's gonna costume
yeah the Sinbad genie movie that's the
one you owe and then oh uh was it
Blankman and when I was meant to be
yeah meteor man um like it's like that's
the big half this movie feels like it
came from that era and the other half
feels like it was like adventures in
babysitting or some pretty 80s movie
that like kids just happen to latch it
like a hint of ghostbusters to a lot of
those moms look like ghostbusters my
veil oh no that's what I love the idea
of kids seeing this and like getting
scared I'm like that's kids need ed yeah
you know what it in that sense reminds
of Ghostbusters is because like
Ghostbusters as an adult is hilarious as
a kid I took some of that shit seriously
ya know when this movie this movie's
similar I think there's scenes that you
know kids will get legit scared but you
know I think the difference or the fight
the difference between something like
that and like some of the other DC
darker films that that didn't work uh
was first of all it's very much not it
does have some light in there you know
Shazam is very funny the kids are very
funny and they're very really there's
like there's a lot of charm to it
there's a lot of charm that brings you
back from the darkness that's okay
second it acknowledges that yes that
this is dark and you're allowed to feel
like this isn't good that this is bad
for you there's a you know the stuff
they do is not good stuff all the time
and stuff like that a beer yes yes you
know I'm going to a strip club and said
things which goes away is well he's 15
he's starting to get up there but like I
remember when I was a kid and I like you
know tried to sit beer that was my
initial reaction was like ya know drink
this zoe has an adult I'm like that's
pretty good there's an acknowledgment
that the dark stuff is there but but it
balances out and it's like you can say
you can be afraid of this where the air
DC films seem to be you know what it's
dark it's great it's tough if you're
easy
fuck you yeah if you're lucky maybe
there'll be a superhero but you know
what they're fuck to they're just like
dead inside like it was just so
miserable where this feels like yeah
there's some miserable creepy
imaginative creepy stuff but hey it can
be kind of fun sometimes you know and
you can
almost gonna get into it and be there's
that charm there's that color there's
that fun at the center of it that gets
you through it
so yeah I think I think what I liked
most about this movie and this is it's
definitely something missing from the
Snyder films but it's just really sweet
hmm
liked it right had that vibe of the
original Donner Superman where it's like
you know what we're allowed to be just
nice yeah thank you so like you know
let's just have fun and this is gonna be
nice and it's gonna be sweet and it's
just gonna you know you're gonna have
somebody to look up to but you can still
have these very inappropriate yeah kids
but I think it's okay because that's
where you step out there but there's
such a good Center it's like when we
were kids and like are as so many
parents I knew when let their kids watch
The Simpsons but we were allowed to
watch even though our but but like our
mom did particularly like necessarily
like that we watch it but she always
said no they come back to good morals
they're good for yeah yeah okay even
though there's a lot of times we've
repeat stuff you know but it's like but
she still let us watch it cuz she knew
this is still essentially good morals
and stuff and that's what this feels
like it doesn't feel like garbage it
feels like if there's real substance
here even though it's silly and it has a
lot of inappropriate stuff in it it's I
all the stuff with the family I'm just
like it was just yeah oh well hey how
many times in a DC comic book movie do
though oh yeah maybe Wonder Woman is the
only time I can think of a couple
moments or I'm like oh that's sweet like
you know yeah definitely not coming up
that kind of naivete like early on
before she became like wise to the world
at war like and I I loved Aquaman but
there's no moments in it um so yeah I
think they're on a roll man let's keep
it going man keep going keep strong
worried yeah I'd love to see DC like you
know how could it yeah what I've even
again even this Joker movie that does
not look light inves
light is I mean you could argue that
looks like maybe while they're heavier
Mumma is fine I welcome it looks like it
has so much my issue is not that DC is
dark my two issues are one half the time
they don't execute dark right I mean I
love that I love the Dark Knight I love
the Tim Burton's Batman Batman Returns
as dark as all hell that's one of my
favorite bit like but just the way
they've executed it it's just not very
interesting my other problem is not that
they do dark it's that they came under
the belief for some reason that it must
be dark it could all may be dark and I'm
like it I'm like no you can do all sorts
of things I'm like I'm glad that they
want to do a Joker movie like and have
it be dark if they want to do a bama
moving that stark that's fine but like
they don't all have to be dark and this
proves it big time or even here like
there are dark moments but but yeah I
don't know if I call it a dark movie
yeah but it's not a dark movie when they
do the dark elements they do it very
well and very Spartan so yeah I say go
see a man it's it's a listen
yeah that's about it it's just good it's
good
go see it
you